(man) The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
Who wants a drink?
You're gonna need a drink.
Saliva goes down,
and they suck it up.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
I'll offer you
a million dollars.
I may consider going in
with big shark daddy here.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
If you take that deal,
you get wiped out right now.
You sold your soul.
You, my friend,
become a millionaire.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
An engineer that comes
on national tv
and can't do their math--
That's not good.
It's sink...
my--My--My--That was--
That was--
or swim.
Okay, kiddies, time for you
to leave the shark tank.
This could get very ugly.
♪♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of qvc,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold
his first internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪♪
First into the shark tank
is Doug Marshall
with the next generation
of face painting.
(chuckles)
Hello, sharks.
My name is Doug Marshall,
and I'm the creator
and owner
of the Game Face company.
We are here seeking
an investment of $450,000...
damn.
For a 25% equity stake
in the Game Face company.
The Game Face
is a patented product
that has revolutionized
the face-painting, makeup,
and costume mask industry.
Avid sport fans love
to paint their face,
and kids of all ages
love trick-or-treating
and dressing up
for halloween.
My son here, will,
is dressed up
for a maverick game
if he could only score
on some tickets.
And Katie, my daughter,
is dressed up
as a butterfly girl.
I would like to give
each of you a face...
I love it when we get
free stuff.
(Lori laughs)
The faces are one size
trimmed to fit.
I'm sporting
the Patriot face right now.
Kevin, what face
are you sporting?
(Lori laughs)
Mr. Wonderful's face.
Always smiling.
I would like to give you
a tiger face.
Ooh!
Thank you, Doug.
Lori, this is
an exotic mask face.
(laughing)
This skeleton face
May do just
the right thing for you.
(Robert) Oh, that's so
perfect for you, Kevin.
I like that.
That is perfect.
Over the past
year and a half,
all of our faces
have been wash-Away faces,
much like a tattoo.
So, we have had inquiries,
and people say,
"Well, why couldn't I
wear a face
and then just be able
to take it off?"
so, if I can grab a--
an edge here
of this face,
and as I peel away...
you can see that I'm not
having to wash it.
Wow!
"Mission: Impossible."
(Lori) so it's
a one-time use, Doug?
Yes.
But it's Peel off,
as opposed to wash off?
Right.
(Robert) It's incredible.
And it's--It's very
comfortable to wear.
I mean... (mouth full)
You can...
what?
Eat it? (laughs)
You can just eat it?
Why?
Is that just a nasty habit,
or are you trying to show us--
It's made with vegetable dyes,
and it's all water-based,
and it's very safe
for kids.
Let's go to the economics.
Tell us about the business,
your revenues, your costs.
We're in our fifth year
of business.
And let me preface this--
This is a part-time job
for me and my wife.
And we literally have an office
above our garage,
and we ship
out of our garage.
Our first year, we did
$6,700 worth of sales,
and last year,
we did $102,000.
We anticipate doing $105,000
this year.
$102,000,
and you are valuing
that you you have a part-time
$1.8 million company...
yes.
In your attic.
Why are you worth
$1.8 million?
Well, first of all, we haven't
even tapped into the big box.
We have about 400 customers
that are all retail,
small mom-and-pop shops.
We have
licensed ncaa teams.
We have a local license--
Texas tech, tcu,
and a&m.
What does it cost you to make?
What do you sell 'em for?
So we wholesale them
for $2.50,
and our cost will range
from 25 cents to 60 cents.
It's all volume-driven.
Great margin.
Only our designs
are all retailed
for $4.99.
(Daymond) It is
a great margin.
(Mark) So you're paying
10 per--
It's a $5 item.
And, Doug, on the $102,000
that you sold last year,
how much money did you
make on that?
We made $32,000.
The numbers just don't add up.
Okay, kiddies, it's time
for you to leave the shark tank.
Your daddy's asked
for $1.8 million value
on his company.
This could get very ugly.
Yeah, we're gonna put on
some ugly faces...
Bye, guys.
And, uh, talk to your Dad.
(laughs)
Are there competitors?
There's no competitors.
Okay.
And there can't be
any competitors,
because of our patent.
(Robert) But--But, Doug,
that can't be true.
I've bought stickers--
the key is full face.
The key is full face.
Full face.
What's your full-time job,
Doug?
I work for xerox
selling copiers.
You've got these big margins.
It's working for you.
Yeah.
Why still sell copiers
instead of do this full-time?
Well, we've got two kids.
We got--
We got into
the real estate bust
in east texas.
Okay, so you gotta
pay the bills, basically.
I gotta pay the bills.
What's the $450,000 for?
$300,000 would get me
on a salary
for the next three years,
get us going
with the licenses.
We want to get nba.
(Daymond) one second,
one second. Doug.
You just basically said,
"I want $100,000 a year
for 3 years."
I think that's absurd.
I-I didn't make any money
from my business for nine years.
I'm out.
Doug, I-I really like
the product.
But I gotta tell you,
when you said,
"I'm gonna take a $100,000
salary for the next 3 years,
and that's why I need
an investment"--
to guarantee that
for the next three years,
with all due respect, you gotta
be friggin' kidding me.
When I started my business,
do you know how many years
before I made $100,000?
And you're coming here
and asking me
to guarantee that for you?
This could turn water
into gold,
but I'm sorry, my friend.
I wouldn't want to invest
alongside with you.
I'm out.
Okay.
(Mark) What are you gonna
use the money for, Doug?
To get me to go full-time
and license acquisitions.
(Kevin) Doug, let me solve
that problem for you right now.
Here's a deal for you.
I'll give you $450,000.
Here's how I'll do it.
I'll give you $150,000
of it
for 30% of your company.
The other $300,000
you've asked for,
I'll give to you as a loan.
And I'm going to put
a 25-cent royalty
on every mask until I get
my $150,000 back.
(Lori) I-I would like
to make you an offer--
the $450,000.
But I'd like Mark
to go in with me.
And for 40% stake.
But I can immediately
get you into all the licensing
and into retailers
all over the country.
I would like to hear from Mark.
He's been awfully quiet.
(Lori) Yes.
Mark, what do you have to say?
Um...
I gotta tell you--
So, when I first
took over the mavs,
no one would go
to the games.
Right? I-I literally
had to hand out tickets.
And one of the promotions
I ran was--
and it's running
to this day--
That if you come
to a mavs game
with your face and/or body
fully painted
in mavs colors,
we're gonna have a contest,
and we'll pick the craziest
and give you free seats.
Yeah.
And it's such a mess.
There's paint.
There's mess everywhere.
Yes.
So I-I can relate.
It's a great option.
Yeah.
Okay, here's the offer
I'll make. Um...
I'll offer you
a million dollars...
Yowza!
For the entire company.
Whoa.
Included
in that million dollars
is a salary to you
of $80,000 a year
for five years.
Lori, I'll bring you in
if you'd like--
if you'd like to come in,
I'm happy to bring you in.
I'm in on Mark's offer.
I like it.
(Kevin) You understand
what's happening to you, right?
If you take that deal,
you get wiped out
right now.
You gave up your future.
You sold your soul.
You own nothing.
♪♪♪
Two sharks are out.
Doug has two offers
on the table--
$450,000 for a 30% stake
and a 25-cent royalty
from Kevin,
and $1 million
for 100% of the company
from Mark and Lori.
(Kevin) You understand
what's happening to you, right?
If you take that deal,
you get wiped out right now.
You gave up your future.
You sold your soul.
You own nothing.
You, my friend,
become a millionaire.
Doug, I saw your soul
drift out of the shark tank.
(mark laughs)
There it goes.
(Lori laughs)
It could've been worth
$15 million, but no.
That's exactly
what's happening.
(laughing)
So, my offer makes
a lot more sense.
I leave 70% of the upside
to you.
It's perfect.
I move lightning-Fast,
and I have all the connections.
I think that mark
would be the right partner.
With his abilities
and with mine together,
this can become
an overnight sensation.
So, Doug, when I started
my business,
a guy came along,
offered me $5 million.
It was more money
than I had ever dreamed of.
I went home,
and I told my wife about it.
And she looked at me
and she said,
"I don't believe
you started this business
"to work for somebody else
one day.
I think you can make it
much bigger."
I was shocked. We had car loans,
we had a huge mortgage.
It was worth hundreds
of millions of dollars,
and I hung on to it.
It was the best decision
I ever made.
What are you going to do?
I would like to, uh,
talk to my family about it.
Okay.
Mark, partnered with Lori,
has offered us,
uh, a million dollars...
(laughs)
In order... (laughs)
You're taking a guy's company
underneath him.
Also, Kevin has offered us
$150,000,
and then would, uh,
bank us on the other $300,000.
(Mark) We sit here
all the time and talk about
how unfortunate
and how tough things are
in this country right now,
and here we are
giving the guy a million dollars--
You're stealing
his American dream.
He's not gonna sell his soul.
You know,
getting this started
has been a huge sacrifice
for us.
Okay.
Okay, Bye.
(kisses)
Love you.
All right. (laughs)
(exhales deeply) Sorry.
(Kevin) What are you gonna do?
All right. Um...
I really think
it's too early in the game
for us
with the Game Face company
to give up 100%
of the company.
Ooh.
But I do like
Lori and Mark working with us.
We could go with the $450,000
and $80,000 in salary,
and we would give out...
35% equity in the company.
So, I would like
to counter back, Mark.
$450,000 at the 40%
that I started with,
and he can get
the $80,000 salary
for the first three years.
I would do
as Lori suggested,
or $450K for 35%
plus the $80k guaranteed
for 3 years,
but a 10% royalty
till we get our money back.
I'm good with that.
(Kevin) It just shows you
my deal is
the right one anyways.
They're just copying my deal.
So it's just a question of how
you value the 5% in equity,
and I'll leave that
up to you.
(Robert) So, Doug, you've
done something remarkable.
You've made Mark Cuban grovel.
(laughs) He has not.
There's no groveling here.
(Lori laughs)
♪♪♪
Well, I like the 35%,
and I like the 10% royalty
on it.
So, Mark and Lori...
Let's do it!
Put your game face on!
Put your game face on, baby!
Whoo!
Let's do it!
Let's do it.
Congratulations, man.
It's gonna be awesome.
Thanks, man.
We'll have fun.
We'll bring you--
Bring the kids down
to a mavs game.
You came here with a company
that makes $30,000 a year,
and you got a million dollar
value. It's unbelievable.
Great job. Wow.
That guy just turned down
a million bucks
and made you guys counteroffer.
I was just trying
to solve his problem,
which was he wanted
security.
And he wanted to walk the rest
of his life with a soul,
and I solved that problem.
(laughs)
I don't think of this
as walking away
from a million dollars.
I think of this as walking
towards $20 or $50 million.
And that's what we're doing.
We're going towards
the future.
♪♪♪
My name is Dan Grimm.
I'm Brant Myers, and we live
in San Luis Obispo, California.
I met Brant
in fifth grade.
We played soccer together.
We were in boy scouts together.
We've been friends
for the past 22 years.
Ooh!
Come on. Yeah.
Brant and I love to do
all sorts of things together.
(whirring)
Dan and I have always
been tinkerers.
So it's really no big jump for
us to go into business together.
He handles one side
of the business
that I don't want to do.
I do the things
that he don't want to do.
(clicking)
between the two of us,
we have one big brain,
and we can get anything done
that we put our mind to.
Well, thank you for your order.
All right, Dan.
We just got another sale.
Let's go celebrate.
Yeah!
(laughs)
(Dan) Our product is...
3-Way split!
Two of our favorite
pastimes in one.
When people first see
our product,
they don't know
what to think,
they don't know what to say.
They just drool.
(clink)
Bom.
Now we need a shark
to take our product
to the masses.
♪♪♪
My name is Dan Grimm,
engineer, gaming nerd.
I'm Brant Myers,
card-carrying beer connoisseur.
Our product is the Arkeg.
And we're offering 33%
of our business
in exchange for $100,000.
We had a house in college
with a "kegerator"
and an arcade game.
First, we turned
the refrigerator
into a kegerator.
Then we fixed up
this old arcade machine
with parts
laying around the house.
We found ourselves
staying in on weekends,
saving a ton of money.
It was Paradise.
I went and poured myself
another beer,
looked back, and saw these
two massive appliances,
and a lightbulb went on.
Well, what if,
with my manufacturing expertise,
and Dan's superb
electronics skills,
we could create a product
that would combine
our two favorite pastimes?
Ladies and gentlemen...
Let me introduce to you
what has been called
the greatest invention
of all time...
the Arkeg!
(laughs)
Ta-Da!
(laughter)
Drink...
drink... and game.
(Lori laughs)
Oh, lord.
Drink n' game!
It not only pours
any beer you want,
but it comes pre-loaded
with some of the most popular
classic arcade games.
Is it a fridge?
It's a keg.
It doesn't just pour beer.
How about some wine
for the chef of the house
after a long day?
(clink)
(laughing)
That's how you drink your wine,
Kevin--From a tap.
Wine's not your thing,
what about some root beer
for the kids
and their friends?
Put one
in your family room,
in your game room,
your man cave.
Who wants a drink?
Guys, you're gonna need a drink
when you try to sell these.
I'm out.
Whoa!
(Brant) That was fast.
That's a record.
Was it the beer, or was it
the game that got you out?
It was the combination
thereof.
I just don't see it, guys.
Sorry.
Wait a minute.
Are you serious with this?
Absolutely.
It's a great product.
(Robert) How much is it?
$4,000 retail.
(Daymond) Wow.
(Kevin) $4,000?
Have you sold any of them?
Absolutely.
We've sold 20.
(Daymond) You come in here,
guys.
You're very, very rude.
You haven't even
offered me a beer.
My apologies, Daymond.
Wine, root beer, beer?
Can I pour that thing?
Let me see that.
(Brant) By all means.
It's actually
capitalizing
on the current trend,
which is
pour your own beer.
What do you got in wine?
Yeah, I'll have a wine.
It's a 2010 estate Pinot noir
from central coast, California.
Oh, please, I'll have some.
Kevin, would like some, uh,
night train or ripple?
No, no, I'm doing some,
uh, pinot, I think.
(laughing)
Thank you very much.
Yes.
I see this as--
As more of a gimmick.
(clink)
I don't see myself
as being in the Arkeg business.
I'm out.
(Robert) I remember
when games like this
were very, very popular.
So I bought, like, 12 games.
I put 'em in my basement.
I thought my friends
could go down there all the time
and play.
I gotta tell you,
I haven't been in that room
for eight years.
You sold 20 units over 2 years.
That's low.
I'm out.
Guys, I think the beauty
of games now
is that they're small,
you can play it on your tablet.
This is just really
a dinosaur.
I just don't think
it's anything for me. I'm out.
Mr. Wonderful,
what are you doing?
I'm, uh, looking at it
as a limited opportunity.
Not every business
is destined to be huge.
I prefer to invest
in the ones that are.
Kevin,
with your capital injection,
we can get
our price point low enough
to get into big box stores.
You're talking about
a high-end refrigerator.
"look, honey, we can get
an arcade game
with beer that comes
out of it."
We have a lot of wives that
buy them for their husbands.
It's a great--
Listen, guys,
I appreciate the wine,
and it's actually
quite good.
Thank you.
I'm gonna take a pass.
I'm out.
No counteroffer?
All right, I'll get Lori
to give you $50,000.
(laughs)
Lori, we'll take it.
(laughter)
Gentlemen, cheers to Arkeg.
Cheers.
Thank you, guys.
Good luck, guys.
(Brant) Appreciate it.
Cheers.
Good luck.
♪♪♪
Only on "Shark tank" would you
see that kind of insanity.
(laughs)
We're disappointed
we didn't get a deal.
But we get to do what we love.
We're still making money,
and... we own 100%
of our business.
♪♪♪
Next up is Dan Rothwell
with a product that aims
to make outdoor eating safer.
♪♪♪
Hello. My name
is Dan Rothwell,
and my product is Dura-tent.
I am seeking $50,000 for a 30%
equity stake in our company.
Spring is the official start
of picnics and parties
with family and friends
in the great outdoors.
But there is nothing
more irritating
than standing around
swatting the flies
away from the food,
and rightfully so.
(laughs)
How many times
have we seen the flies
hovering around and getting
on that dog poop
and walking around?
(buzzing)
Then that fly says...
(Mark laughs)
"there's a party going on.
I'm gonna go walk
on that potato salad."
(laughing)
And it does.
And it leaves behind
little particulate
of the disgust it just
picked up along the way.
Ew.
Poop potato salad,
anybody?
No, thank you.
Stop the madness.
(laughter)
Let's take a look at a clip
of a fly's day.
(Robert laughs)
Here's flies swarming
around the garbage.
Now they stick
their tongue out,
and saliva goes down, and they
mix it with your food,
and they suck it up,
and it's disgusting.
Flies leave behind parasites,
larvae, salmonella,
and even antibiotic-Resistant
e. Coli.
The same types of bacteria
that hospitalize
thousands of people
across the U.S.
Each and every year,
and unfortunately,
some of these people die.
Is this what you want for your
family and friends, sharks?
No!
Exactly not.
Our solution
to this problem
is the dura-Tent.
(sharks laughing)
As you can see,
it's a full enclosure.
Are we going camping
with that food?
We're going to the backyard
parties and picnics.
It's a full enclosure, not just
a little pop-up umbrella.
A little velcro on the door.
Flip it up, get your food.
Look at how much food
this protects.
Easy to clean,
easy to set up.
My customers love the product.
With your help,
we can not only make this
a national success,
but an international success.
How many have you sold?
50,000 units.
(Robert) Wow.
Wow.
Where do you sell them?
How much do they sell for?
It sells for $19.95--
On my picnic.
My banquet--Between, uh,
$29.95 and $34.95.
What's your cost?
My cost is, uh,
$4.65 on my picnic
and $7.27 on my banquet.
Out of the 50,000,
where are most of them sold?
County fairs.
This is a product
that screams demonstration.
That's the problem, right?
Or screams a media
that gets into the, uh,
awareness of people
that they have the product
available to them,
so when they go into the store
and they see it, so...
I've seen little mesh screens...
yes.
That you put over
individual bowls
or plates.
Yep.
Why is this better?
We are a full enclosure.
It is not going to
blow away on you.
You have a large banquet,
you're having a lot of food.
So, Dan, how did you
come up with this?
What's your background?
I'm an engineer--
Electrical engineer.
Uh, pulse power,
power electronics.
I went fusion research
to excimer laser technology,
and I sold my stock
and stepped away.
My goal was to take
a product from inception
to the consumer market.
I had some
technology ideas.
We're sitting around
my brother-In-Law's pool,
and mom is doing this, and we
came up with some sketches.
So you go from high-Tech
laser blasting aliens
to fly tents?
Exactly.
I love it.
(laughs)
But the numbers don't add up.
If you've got 300% margins
and you're doing $140,000
in business,
um... right?
Yes.
Then how--why don't you have
just a huge bottom line?
I'm--So last year, the majority
of my business was wholesale
more than it was retail.
Gotcha. Okay,
what's the breakdown?
7,800 in year 1...
Oh.
10,000 in year 2,
13,000, uh, in year 3,
and I'm on track to, uh,
be around 13,000 this year.
The numbers didn't add up
to me.
You said that you sold
50,000 of these
in the last three years.
But then you said
you sold 13,000...
50,000--
13,000 and 7,800.
Is that what you said?
First year was, uh,
7,800, 10,000,
13,000, and through today.
My apologies.
So this year,
you gonna do 19,000?
Pardon?
It's still not adding up.
Yeah, 'cause This year, you
would have to do 19,000 units.
'cause you came up
to 41,000 units.
My apology--My--My--
No, $31,000. You came up
to $31,000.
So, So, technically,
what have you sold?
An engineer that comes
on national tv
and can't do their math--
(Kevin) Oh...
that's not good. (laughs)
(Robert) So what--
my--My--My--That was--
That was--
So what's the math, Dan?
It--it--No. My apology.
35,000 heading
towards 40,000.
Dan, do you have a patent
on this?
Yes, we actually have,
uh, three patents in total.
Once we--
what is the chance
we could go
to one of the largest companies
that makes tent supplies
and say,
"listen, license my fly tent.
Let's get in bed together"?
the right deal, Kevin,
without a doubt,
but I'd like to know
the marketing plan behind that.
Well, I mean--
So, tell us specifically
how you would use
the $50,000
and how you think that'll
accelerate your sales?
Mark, the $50,000
is well thought-out.
I did
the national hardware show.
I had two key reps
into qvc.
Both of 'em
sent me contracts.
All roads lead to Lori.
So, $50,000 plus 50,000
that I have of inventory,
plus getting that pipeline
ready for our qvc.
We gotta keep pushing
This thing
until the big buyer
box stores pull it
because the consumer
wants it.
Well, Dan, let's--Let's hear
what Lori has to say.
So reps want to rep product.
Yes.
So of course
they're going to anything
that piques their interest,
because they don't have
anything to lose.
They can try,
get it on, see if it works.
Yes. Yes.
You know, it's not their money.
They didn't invest
in the product.
I agree.
Dan, I-I--You know,
I'm just, uh,
I'm just
a simple croatian guy.
My mother would have died
if I put my food
under a tent outside.
So I'm just not buying
into the concept of...
okay.
"Let's have a picnic
and put our food in the tent."
Yeah. (laughs)
I mean, I can't get there.
I'm out.
Thank you
for your consideration...
very much, Robert.
I think it's
an ingenious product.
Thank you.
And I think
it's well engineered.
You've really thought it out
and done some--
Some great things with it.
I just can't really
add value to it.
So with that, I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
I believe you're gonna
sell a bunch of fly tents.
I really do.
Thank you.
Thank you, Kevin.
Uh, well, don't thank me yet.
Well--
you haven't heard my offer.
♪♪♪
Two sharks are out,
but Kevin O'Leary
seems interested.
I believe you're gonna
sell a bunch of fly tents.
I really do.
Thank you.
Thank you, Kevin.
Uh, well, don't thank me yet.
You haven't heard my offer.
(laughs)
I'll give you the $50,000,
but I don't want any equity
in your company at all.
What I want is a way
to get my money back
if you're successful.
Every time you sell one
of the smaller ones, I want $2,
and every time you sell
one of the big ones,
I want $2.50.
If you just stay on track,
I'll get my money back
in two years.
Which I don't--
is, you know, not unreasonable.
Then I start to collect profits
in years three and four.
Assuming you don't get
eaten by a fly.
That's... (laughs)
I appreciate
that offer, Kevin,
but what I'm really
looking for
is somebody who has
the marketing vision
that can help get--
That gets that--
Well, I have that, too.
That's my partner Lori.
She's gonna give you that.
(laughter)
I may consider going in
with big shark daddy here.
Ooh...
But--But--
Big shark daddy?
I have some more questions.
(laughing)
Did you like the structure
of my deal, Lori?
No.
Really?
Because--No. I don't.
It's a lot of money
that you're asking
off of each one.
How do we get our money back?
How do we get
our money back?
Well, let me ask
a couple of questions.
Why'd you name it dura-Tent?
Shouldn't it be, like,
"fly be gone,"
or "No more fly," or...
dura-Tent. Dura platter.
Dura picnic items.
I worked
with a marketing company.
The person said,
"your name does not need
"to describe the product
as much as the tagline
needs to describe it."
"dura-Tent," now you can
take the "tent" away
and you can add on
accessories.
(Robert) but it's not a tent.
If that's on a shelf,
I could see people
walking right past it...
exactly.
And not having any idea
what it was,
because "Dura-Tent" doesn't mean
anything about covering food...
and--
From flies.
Usually I feel that, you know,
I can tell instantly
if it's a hero or a zero.
My problem here is,
I'm not sure there's
this huge demand for it.
And so actually,
for that reason, I'm out.
(Kevin) Whoa, Dan.
And I'm the only shark up here
that speaks fly.
Daymond... I don't know
if you said...
Well, Dan, um,
I was on the fence.
So whether I like
to admit it or not,
I probably learn more
from the sharks up here
that are experts
in their field.
I'm gonna have to learn
from Lori's decision here.
I'm out.
And, Lori, there's no way
to come back in?
(Kevin) okay.
I'm sorry.
Just to be clear, Dan,
you are turning down my offer?
I don't think
he turned it down just yet.
At this level, you know...
obviously you'd hate
to turn down an offer,
but money isn't my problem
right now.
If we were to land
a big box store--
You did--You didn't
come here for money?
I... my goal was to take--
to--to take a product from
inception into the marketplace.
But that requires money.
Exactly. But it also requires
the marketing side of this.
But for you to give me
$50,000 and say,
"just pay me back,"
that doesn't get me
to the next level.
Ooh, Kevin, he's saying
there's smart money,
and there's dumb money,
and you're dumb money.
I want to save lives.
I want to save children.
I want to kill flies.
I am going to make it
more interesting for you, Dan,
and here's my new offer--
I'm giving you nothing.
However, I will buy
a small tent from you
at the full retail price
to help you,
but my offer
is off the table.
I'm out.
You just got $20
without a perpetual license.
That's good.
(Daymond) Good luck, man.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I'm the only shark
that believed in you.
♪♪♪
No deal is better
than a bad deal.
That's very True, mark.
He turned down
a very good deal.
He was very smart
to turn down your deal.
No, he wasn't.
That was a horrible deal.
♪♪♪
Last season on "Shark Tank"...
what year in school--You said
you're sophomores still, or--
We're about to be juniors.
You're about to be juniors.
At the university of oregon.
And I'm gonna make you rich.
We watched Erika Welsh
and Keeley Tillotson
strike a deal
with Barbara Corcoran
for their
wild squirrel nut butter.
Let's see what they're
up to now.
(ship horn blows)
(chitters)
Yes, we'll have 500 jars
to you next week.
Thanks for your call.
The biggest thing
we learned from the sharks
was that we couldn't
do it all.
We couldn't be
full-time college students
while running our business.
So after the show,
we decided that we were
going to put
our college careers on hold
to pursue wild squirrel
full-Time.
It's the best decision
we've ever made.
This is, like,
everybody's favorite.
Yeah, honey pretzel,
the chocolate sunflower seed.
Before "Shark Tank,"
we had $16,000 in revenue,
and since "Shark Tank,"
in Less than a year
we've sold over $350,000 worth
of peanut butter.
We have projected sales
of $1.2 million
in the next 12 months.
Oh, look, Keeley!
Look, look, look!
Oh, my gosh!
Look at this display!
Oh, my gosh, it looks amazing!
It is so gratifying
to walk into a store
and see our peanut butter
on store shelves.
The "Shark Tank" experience has
completely changed our lives.
Who would have thought
that two girls from Oregon
would have dropped out
of college
to run
a peanut butter company?
All of our hard work
has finally paid off.
♪♪♪
(squawking)
My name's Megan Gage,
and I live
just outside
of Denver, Colorado,
with my family,
and they're everything to me.
Whee! (laughs)
My son Christian is 3.
He's a boy.
He likes dirt and trucks
and tools,
but he always looks handsome.
(laughs)
Look at mommy!
(giggles)
Moms want the best
for their kids,
and a lot of the time,
the things on the market
are not the best, and I wanted
to create something
that could really
give my son some style.
Hi. How are you?
Here's 40 more.
Okay.
I grew up
in a really small town.
My dad was a coal Miner,
and most people
in the town were.
It taught the value
of hard work, and I think that
that was something
that I'll always carry with me.
We can get
that right out to you guys.
I entered into an industry
where I knew nothing
about nothing.
It feels really impossible
to get noticed.
My family worked hard
for the money we put in this.
Getting an investment
from the sharks
would give me that partner
I need
so that I could sleep better
at night,
knowing that things are
gonna be okay
and that I didn't lose
our money.
♪♪♪
(Mark) Oh-Ho!
Aw.
(gasps) Oh...
(Lori laughs)
Hi, guys.
My name is Megan Gage,
and I'm the creator
of hot tot
children's hair care.
I'm seeking
a $50,000 investment
in exchange for a 15%
equity stake in my business.
Hot tot produces
professional hair products
for babies and children
without the use
of harsh or harmful chemicals.
Moms take great pride
in having our little ones
Look adorable
from head to toe.
I have always liked for
Christian to have stylish hair.
(spritzing)
This is just water, guys.
(Robert laughs)
I gotta get it going
in the right direction.
(laughs)
But the fruity-Scented
children's lines
with cartoonish-Looking labels
didn't appeal to me at all.
Traditional formulas leave
a residue in his hair
that was pretty difficult
to remove
and also didn't smell
very good or work very well.
(sharks laughing)
Punk it up.
That's right!
(laughter)
You may be surprised to know
that many trusted
children's brands
commonly use a long list
of unsafe ingredients
in their formulas--
Things like formaldehyde
which are not even required
to be listed on a label.
I'm a mom with a conscience
who won't cut corners
when it comes to kiddos.
You're doing so good.
And my products can easily
be assimilated
into any upscale salon
throughout the world.
I just need your help
in getting them on the shelves.
Please help me in turning
cool kids across the world
into hot tots.
Is that your son?
It is, yes.
This is my little guy.
(Daymond) Adorable.
(Robert) What's his name?
His name is Christian.
Can you wave at everybody?
Great job, Christian.
How old is he?
(Lori) He's so cute.
He just turned 3.
(Robert) oh!
Oh!
(Mark) Megan, tell us
about the business.
Okay, absolutely.
Um, we've been in business
for about 15 months.
We started
in children's boutiques.
That was originally my goal
for the line.
Um, but we've learned
that salons
are really
our bread and butter.
And Christian's gotta go,
guys. I'm so sorry.
Bye, Christian.
See you, Christian.
Later, Chris.
Can you wave good-Bye
to the sharks?
(Robert) See ya.
Oh!
So, Megan, what--
What were your sales
in the last 15 months?
We've made about $20,000.
Um, but in
the past 12 days,
I've got $7,000
in purchase orders.
What happened
in the last seven days?
I met a very nice lady,
and she gave me some contacts
with some of
the children's flash sites,
where they'll do like
a 24-Hour promotion
on your brand.
And everyone I reached out to,
um, was interested.
This was never my dream.
If you would have asked me
four years ago,
I would have said
This was a crazy idea.
May still be.
It's--It's not, uncle Kevin.
Uncle Kevin! (laughs)
Please, call me "Mr. Wonderful."
Absolutely.
So this is a styling aid.
It's good for boys and girls,
for people who are concerned
about using
a hair product
on their baby.
Oh, it smells good.
My professional background
is in clinical social work.
I have a master's degree
in social work.
(Robert) So you're not
a hair stylist?
I'm not.
The packaging, to me,
looks like
something
that would be for an adult.
I mean, it's very pretty, but it
doesn't say to me "children."
I think it needs to say
that it's for children
and that it's healthier,
that it has
those safer elements to it.
Are you opposed to changing
your packaging?
Um, I don't think I would be
interested in changing it.
Here's why.
You know, we're not the only
children's line on the market.
You're not.
I know that.
Right.
But the other ones all had,
like, cartoon-Looking
animals and children,
and they smelled like fruit.
Are they safer, too? Do they--
No.
They're not? So there is
a distinct difference...
absolutely.
Between yours and theirs?
(Mark) Megan,
I have a 3-year-Old son.
I know you do.
Jake.
And jakers has got eczema.
Yep.
And who knows
what other allergies he has?
So what type
of allergy testing
have you done
with these products?
Absolutely. My manufacturer
does a lot of, um,
like, stability testing
and micro testing
and things like that.
(Kevin) But do you have
the market size
for children's products
like this,
including
all your competitors?
'cause that's what
I'm struggling with.
How big a market is this?
Well, there are 280,000
salons in America alone.
The global baby care
market
Does $48 billion a year
and is expected to grow
by 5% in the next 5 years.
She's killing you, Kevin!
Way to take it to him, Megan.
That's not the hair.
(mark laughs)
You're talking about
all the products--
That's okay.
What about
the baby hair products?
Well, there's not
a lot of numbers on that,
'cause it's new.
I mean, it's just
kind of getting started.
But with $20,000 in sales,
why do you feel it could be
something huge?
Uh, because people
get excited about it.
They say, "Hey,
that's a good idea.
Why didn't I think of that?"
I've had two calls
in the past two weeks
from distributors
in dubai.
In dubai?
(Lori) in dubai.
It's amazing.
We've been featured
by over a hundred
different media sources,
from, you know, mom blogs
to beauty blogs to magazines.
You know, I--
So why haven't you
sold more, though?
I mean, so you see--See why
we're seeing a disconnect here?
Something's not adding up.
I tell you, all the work
you've done,
the way you present yourself,
your vision for the product--
That's all on the good side.
Where I really have
a problem is $20,000.
It's speaking to me, saying,
"nobody cares."
You know, I did
my first trade show,
and I sat in Dallas,
and they said, "prepare,
"because they're gonna
eat you for breakfast.
They are not gonna be
receptive to this."
And I thought, okay.
But, like, I drug my family
across the country,
and I'm not gonna make
a dime?
And we were there,
and we sold $1,000 in 2 days.
Which is nothing to you guys.
I know that.
Um, but it was something
to me.
I love every $1,000 equally.
Have those folks reordered?
They have.
My average wholesale markup
is 142%,
and my average retail markup
is 284%.
Um, as we make
more product...
great markup.
Great markup.
We can get better margins.
I have one--
(Lori) That's a great markup.
Get better margins that that?
We can. Absolutely.
Yeah. That's...
um, because my costs
to make these
have come down considerably,
um, since we got started,
because I'm learning things.
So, Megan, you've created
maybe a new category.
But $20,000 of sales
in the hair care product
Industry is absolutely nothing.
It's not even a rounding error.
It's mist.
I can't get over the Hurdle
of whether This is
a business or not.
I just don't know,
and neither do you.
So for that reason, I'm out.
Thank you, Kevin.
But I do know it's a business.
I just wanted
to clarify that.
I took a lot of heat
in the beginning
because people would say,
"you're not a hair stylist.
You're a social worker."
And then I had the epiphany
that these products
are not for hair stylists.
Moms are gonna be the ones
to buy these products.
And when it's important,
moms will listen.
You know, I didn't do so well
in chemistry in college.
I would be honest,
but when I learned about
the toxins
in children's products
and their effects
on a growing body,
I learned--
Moms can figure this out.
Then don't--don't you think
we have to take it further
and actually test and label that
we've tested for these things?
Because--
Absolutely, But those kind of
studies are very expensive.
H-Have you priced them out
to know how much?
I know an optical test
costs about $10,000.
And if you look at my labeling,
we do not
use the term "Tear-Free."
I cannot afford
to use that term right now.
I-I think
it needs to be branded
a little bit more
towards children. Um...
sure.
My heart is with you,
but my gut right now is,
I feel there's a lot of work
to be done.
Sure.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
(Mark) Megan,
I'll make it simple. I like it.
And obviously, I have
a personal connection.
I think $50,000
is not enough.
And for me, the testing
is the most important,
because if I can invest
in a product
that makes my kid's life
a little bit better
and opens a new market
and has a chance to be
successful, that's a no-Brainer.
So I want to make you
an offer.
I want to offer you $75,000
for 40% of the company.
You know, we'll help you
get out there into salons.
We'll help you get
into the kids' market.
Sure.
So if that's something
you'd be interested in,
I'd like to partner with you.
Oh, my goodness, mark.
You know, I--
out of respect
for everybody else,
I'd like to hear what
anyone else has to say.
No disrespect.
No disrespect taken.
(Robert)
Wow, what a great answer.
Megan, I'm sitting here
and--and I'm thinking,
is it brilliant?
Have you created
a brand-New category
in hair salons?
Or... is it gonna be
a really, really tough road?
I don't know.
I think mark's made you
a fantastic offer.
Frankly, better than I--
I would have made.
Uh... I'm out.
So, a friend of mine
is Paul Mitchell.
Mm-Hmm.
But I have to be honest.
I think, uh, cuban is ready
to take the ride with you
all the way.
I wouldn't be
of any help to you
if that one person I know
says, "beat it," all right?
So I guess I'm out.
Okay. Mark, I would love
to work with you.
(Kevin) Well, wait a sec.
Wait a sec.
Wait--I was--
there's no waiting.
Wait a second.
That's it.
Shake her hand.
Thank you, mark.
Wow.
I'm so excited.
Thanks, Megan.
Thank you guys so much.
I really appreciate it.
Fantastic presentation.
(Daymond) Good luck.
Good luck.
Thank you, guys.
(Robert) Fantastic.
(Kevin) That's interesting.
I mean, either she's got
a category killer,
or there isn't a category.
That's okay. My kids will use
all the lotion that's left then.
(laughter)
This means everything.
It means that
I can make a product...
(voice breaking)
and it's not gonna take
the last 10 cents
out of my bank account.
Like, it's amazing. (crying)
(whispers) It's amazing.